apples 2019 IMAX are very impressive in
terms of performance like Apple sells on
their site pretty freakin powerful if
you need a fast on a Mac at a reasonable
price there's never been a better time
to buy but at the same time I'm a bit
disappointed hey guys it's max for max
Tech and today we're reviewing apples
2019 IMAX the one I have next to me here
is a fully spec top model as an Intel 8
quart I 9 processor that clocks all the
way up to 5 gigahertz new Vega 48
graphics and 64 gigabytes of RAM that we
added ourselves to save 680 dollars if
you want to know how you could do the
same thing check out our step by step
guide right over here I'll be comparing
performance using this high-end model
but I'll also be commenting on the lower
end models including the 4k the cyanine
machine is powerful as it should be but
it did get about $550 more expensive
than the previous spec top model if we
look at benchmarks it smokes at 2017
iMac and even beats out the iMac Pro in
Cinebench
and also in Geekbench fours multi-core
score scoring eight percent higher but
if we look at single core performance
it's actually a massive 25 percent
better even though both of them are 8
core CPUs if you're a photo editor this
iMac performs just as well as iMac Pro
but costs $2,200 less since you don't
need the better graphics if you're a
video editor the i9 iMac beats out the
pro and most tests we ran in my detailed
video editing comparison resulting in
13% faster speeds overall while costing
a lot less money now if you want a game
a bit after the work is done this iMac
performance very closely to the iMac pro
as well why in the world when Apple
released such a powerful machine that
beats out the iMac Pro well in all
honestly they didn't and I'll tell you
how in just a bit
this great performance is not only
available in a top spec iodine model but
also brought down through the other
models have a bit less cache go for the
i5 model which is now a 6 core and it's
faster than the previous top spec i7
while costing $300 less than before and
on top of that the 5 ATX graphics are
now slightly faster than they were as
well it's nice to see Apple offering
more performance for less money
which honestly is the way text should be
but it's been real
rare to see with Apple lately if you're
on a lower budget the 21 and a half inch
models now come with six core CPUs and
better graphics as well and you can even
get the bag of 20 graphics like the top
spec MacBook Pros which are great for
video editing all of this seems great so
where are the downsides
well other than performance nothing else
has changed first off Apple is still
shipping their lower and IMAX with a
slow 1 terabyte laptop hard drive
everyone complained in 2017 that a
sealed machine that costs over $1000
ships with a slow laptop hard drive but
in 2019 it's really getting ridiculous
hard drives and SSDs have come down in
price a lot so Apple really needs to
start off the imax with their fusion
drives and lower the price of their SSDs
next is the overall design yes it's the
iconic iMac look that's been around for
about 10 years now
but compared to everything else that's
out there in Apple's lineup it really
looks dated we were really hoping for
something with thinner bezels and chin
and maybe even a 1080p webcam but nope
as far as IO the ports are exactly the
same as before to Thunderbolt 3 ports
for USBs the same slow speed SD card
reader that's been around forever and
the standard 1 Gigabit Ethernet this
part really made no sense to me since
Apple gives you the option of adding 10
Gigabit Ethernet to their $800 Mac Mini
but nope that's not here that $800 Mac
Mini also has 4 Thunderbolt 3 ports two
USB s and also HDMI 2.0 along with that
it also has the t2 chip just like every
current Mac that Apple sells other than
the 2019 IMAX I know some people don't
like it because there were some crashes
and because it locks down your data but
there are a ton of benefits like better
webcam footage
microphone quality fast data encryption
without slowing down your CPU h.265
encoding and more for me the biggest
thing is working with the new HEV see
footage for video editing that c2 chip
really speeds up renders and it's going
to matter more and more as we go into
the future looking at all the things
that are missing there's only two
explanations that could make sense to me
and both of them are probably true first
Apple probably didn't want to completely
destroy their entry-level iMac pro
even updated the way it is 2019 iodine
iMac is already cannibalizing so my Mac
Pro sales but if we got more Thunderbolt
ports 10 video to Internet and the t2
chip it would definitely destroy it
upgrading just a CPU and graphics and
not touching anything else makes it seem
like they spent as little time and
effort and Rd as possible they have to
catch up to the market and use Intel's
newest ships but they avoided doing
anything else because of this I think
Apple is likely working on a brand new
redesigned for its IMAX possibly
including the new widescreen 6k display
if they are it would make financial
sense for them to offer the new design
in the iMac pros first and then bring
that down to regular IMAX about a year
or so later there are really two ways at
looking at this new iMac and I'm kind of
mixed on one side we have way more
performance than ever even beating out
the much more expensive iMac Pro and
many weights but on the other hand Apple
left out some updates that really should
have made it in like more thunder both
three ports and the teacher along with
that this is likely the last year that
app was going to be using this design so
you have to ask yourself do I really
need a new iMac right now if you do go
ahead and buy one you'll have a great
experience with lower price to
performance than view 4 or much faster
overall performance and along with that
fan noise is much lower than before even
with the I 9 now if you don't need a new
machine right now you'll be better off
waiting for the major redesign that is
likely coming our way thanks for
watching this has been max with Mac's
tech if you want to see more videos like
this one click that little circle above
and we have a lot of other videos
covering these new iMacs both are
overheating and fan video along with
gaming performance and a comparison to
the iMac pro we'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]